if you really believe suburbs are gonna
die then let them die and let the market
address the situation in a great nation
like ours you could let people do what
they want it has to be coordinated Los
Angeles seems like this big sprawling
mass almost designed to give planners
and ambitious politicians splitting
headaches but should it LA is spread out
and yes there are a lot of cars which is
why politicians and planners want LA to
be more like New York with its
high-density living towering skyscrapers
and state-of-the-art subway system and
they want to do it by pushing
Californians away from cars and
single-family houses building
single-family homes and large Lots is
not gonna be very popular single-family
homes into small lots and multi-family
will be more popular more affordable
Hasani krodha runs the Southern
California Association of Governments
skag skag coordinates planning for all
of Southern California
it subsidizes government projects and
hands out lucrative contracts to big
developers who help implement its vision
of a denser Southern California we can
add 4 billion people to the state in the
next 25 years the demographic shifts
rising cost of commuting the rising cost
of gasoline energy is gonna kind of
probably have people think again about
their choices were to live there's no
massive movement of young people into
Los Angeles it just isn't so where is
the market Joe Kotkin Chapman University
professor and author of the next hundred
million points out the for more than a
decade more people are moving out of
California that are moving in so why the
push for more density Kotkin points to
an ideology called Smart Growth the
Smart Growth I think it was very much
based on this idea that you had to
control what was going on with a very
centralized plan also this really is a
way about favoring well entrenched
developers against either
entrepreneurial developers and in many
ways favoring urban developers over
those who are in the suburb so there's a
confluence of kind of an ideology or
religion of smart growth with a powerful
economic force
of rent-seeking capitalists who support
it
we are purported for us planning for the
future
we're proponent for us coordinating
infrastructure with how we're gonna grow
if that's what you call smarter growth
so be it
you really do as land-use planning is
have to look blocked by a block parcel
by parcel to see what's appropriate and
unfortunately the people who lead these
conversations for Smart Growth have
other interest Damian Goodman lives in
Leimert Park one of LA's historic black
neighborhoods
he runs the Crenshaw subway coalition
and says that planners who plot
high-density projects like New York
style rail into existing neighborhoods
can do more harm than good many people
see a light rail and they think the San
Francisco trolley line well this isn't
the San Francisco trolley line we're not
just putting down some tracks and having
the toot-toot go down while the train
goes 15 miles per hour and people hop on
in every corner the fact that you have a
blue line and you have stations on
Washington Boulevard and that you've had
limited to no economic development along
that corridor it's proof positive that
simple transit access is not enough to
bring about economic development that
you can have transit riders and still
destroy a community one of the things
that happen when you when you force this
high density development is you destroy
the very urban neighborhoods that have
retained in the request take Lamarck
Park Baldwin ELLs people are in the city
because they like being closer in but
they want to have a house in the
backyard the perverse effect of this
policy is to chase the middle class out
of the city the planners have this idea
this is how a city should look
everything should be ascending to the
high point of Manhattan which by the way
has the most distorted distribution of
income of any place in the United States
you can try and fight it but I you know
it combines the most powerful interest
within the city of Los Angeles labor
contractors and developers if you think
you can beat all three of them good luck
the problem with regional planning
organizations is they tend to be
top-down and dominated by the local
elites the neighborhoods have to fight
this almost a kind of guerilla style
like the Vietcong you know they have to
fight in their neighborhoods they're
trying to do something here and then
everybody gets upset the big developer
they have professional meeting goers who
go to meetings unions have their hacks
that do things the Greens have all sorts
of money and they can send people to
these meetings we have to make a living
we have to support our family we have to
take our kids to school we don't have
time to do that to those who say that
the scag isn't a you know go I'm be
disconnected from what's happening in
the ground I would say this if it's not
scaring than what one of the things that
differentiate us from other dishes in
the world is we do play take Bombay
India you go there and tell me that by
letting people do what their worth is a
good a good way in the future if you
really believe suburbs are gonna die
then let them die and let the market
address the situation let people's
preferences and express themselves a
little bit we don't know where we're
going necessarily and the irony of this
push for high-density planning is that
even though la is less dense than save
Manhattan if you zoom out a bit Los
Angeles Long Beach Anaheim is the
densest urban area in the country what
say you New York New York the key thing
that makes la different and most
American cities different from New York
is something called history New York was
developed primarily before the
automobile la is an entrepreneurial city
dominated by small businesses the vast
majority of its growth test taking place
under the automobile and so that's its
DNA now you can think about how you
improve that and make it work but you
can't fundamentally change it maybe all
the so-called sprawl isn't so bad after
all it's what makes LA LA which is more
like a bunch of smaller cities crammed
together inside of the bigger city from
the walkable beach towns of Santa Monica
and Venice on the west side to the
tourist friendly district of Hollywood
to the historic single-family homes of
Lamarque Park do we really need a
handful of planners designing growth
patterns when we could have thousands of
individual choices shaping a city for
reason TV I'm Zack Weisman